Wird das mammut schon bald wiederbelebt
forschungsteams tüfteln schon länger daran science fiction drehbücher zur realität werden zu lassen und sie sind tatsächlich
optimistisch dass sie bereits in naher zukunft
Ausgestorbene tiere wie etwa das mammut wieder zum leben erwecken können und das könnte wiederum eines unserer größten probleme der zeit lösen den
klimawandel verlangsamt wie man genau das mammut von den toten
Wieder erwecken will und alle weiteren infos zu diesem atemberaubenden plant jetzt in fix und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es geht um marmor
wandert tauben und den magen brüter frosch das sind einige der tierarten die längst ausgestorben sind die aber demnächst vielleicht wieder
Auf der erde leben könnten zumindest wenn es nach dem plan der so genannten die extinction
Bewegung geht grob übersetzt sind dass die leute die sich um die wiederbelebung
ausgestorbener tierarten kümmern der genetiker george church ist daran beteiligt und forscht an der renommierten harvard university in boston
Manche bezeichnen ihn als den einstein unserer zeit seinen plan er will ein embryo entwickeln das halb elefant und halb
Wollhaarmammut ist und dass in naher zukunft das hat er im februar diesen jahres auf einer wichtigen wissenschaftskonferenz
der american association for the advancement of science aaas
Oder es in boston verkündet beide tiere kennen wir elefanten aus dem zoo oder einer safari und das wollhaarmammut
Aus dem museum groß wie der heutige steppen elefant aus afrika aber deutlich kräftiger
stoßzähne die nach oben zeigen und ein langes zotteliges fell seit 4000 jahren etwa ausgestorben doch bald werden sie wieder durch die tundra
trampeln und dabei vielleicht sogar den klimawandel stoppen
bot also von vorne forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten schon seit jahrzehnten daran längst
ausgestorbene tiere von den toten zu erwecken doktor frankenstein quasi mit verschwundenen tieren vor rund 14 jahren
Hatten sie zellkerne aus dem letzten exemplar der ausgestorbenen
pyrenäen steinböcke entnommen und diese in ziegen eingesetzt und das ganze war wirklich vielversprechend
Im sommer 2003 kam ein steinböck land zur welt und lebte allerdings nur für kurze zeit nach wenigen minuten erstickt ist
zurück zum mammutprojekt
Forschungsteams hatten es tatsächlich relativ einfach das erbgut von mammut zu entschlüsseln denn
Im permafrost der tundra gab es ziemlich gut erhaltene mammut überreste zu finden das genom des prähistorischen
Mannes wurde also sequenziert doch das problem hierbei das erbgut zu entschlüsseln heißt eben noch lange nicht. Zu wissen an welcher position
welcher gegend bausteinen liegt doch die
sogenannte christa methode ein genetisches werkzeug war dass wir hier ja schon öfter berichtet haben die hilft da enorm weiter mit dieser technik lassen sich
gibt ausschneiden verändern und auch wieder in fremdes erbgut einsetzen der molekularbiologe church hat nach eigenen angaben seit
2015 mehr als
45 mammut gehen stücke in das erbgut des asiatischen elefanten eingesetzt das ist der nächste noch lebende verwandte des wollhaarmammuts
Ganz wichtig dieser prozess ist nicht gleichzusetzen mit dem klonen wie es etwa
Im film jurassic park der fall ist es irgendwann tatsächlich also eine art mama fand zum leben erweckt werden würde hätte es auch schon
Eine heimat im nordosten sibiriens hat ein team aus ökologen und ökologie die tundra zurück in die eiszeit gebiet auf einer gasstätte
neben bereits große pflanzenfresser wie wisente und rentiere
Das sogenannte willi members projekt verspricht sich von diesem plan großes denn die dann
ausgewilderten mammuts könnten tatsächlich helfen den klimawandel, zu bekämpfen
manche von euch wissen vielleicht das im permafrost der
sibirischen steppe gigantische mengen an kohlenstoff eingeschlossen sind und durch die erwärmung der erde kommen wir immer näher an den punkt an dem der
Permafrost taut und genau das will das projekt verhindern denn dann würde der kohlenstoff
entweichen denn tiere wie bisons rentiere oder eben auch mammuts fressen
riesige mengen an pflanzen und das fördert das wachstum des steppengras und dadurch würde tatsächlich
weniger permafrost owen die erklärung dazu die hellen gräser reflektieren das sonnenlicht
Ähnlich wie ein spiegel die erde nimmt weniger wärme auf ein genialer plan und natürlich eine riesige revolution in der wissenschaft doch
Dazu muss ja erst einmal das wollhaarmammut von den toten auferstehen und davon ist das projekt
tatsächlich noch entfernt hinzu kommen mehr als ein bis zwei moralische und ethische bedenken
kritiker sagen die beteiligten
Forschungsteams würden sich durch diese pläne wie gott aufspielen ist es auf der anderen seite nicht eine korrektur wenn wir menschen
ausgestorbene tiere zurück bringen deren ausrottung wir selbst zu verantworten haben wobei das gilt nicht für das mammut andere kritiker sprechen von
Frankenstein methoden und wieder andere fordern das investierte geld besser zu nutzen um noch lebende arten zu schützen
als mehr als fraglich jedenfalls bezeichnen einige andere wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler den plan von george church
langfristig ein war tigges wollhaarmammut zu erschaffen
deutlich realistischer erscheint dagegen der erste schritt dahin ein elefant mit einigen merkmalen der eigentlichen
Ausgestorbenen mammuts es wird also wirklich sehr spannend und auch ein bisschen
Spooky wie ich finde ich halte euch hier auf jeden fall auf dem laufenden
Wenn ihr mir hier ein abo aufs auge
drückt und nicht vergessen mir einen
auf die glocke zu geben denn nur dann verpasst ihr kein video hier geht es weiter mit und dafür drauf klicken werden
gehen soldaten jetzt realität auch eine beängstigende perspektive bis dann
bleibt